we sometimes find ourselves in newish
professional settings or social
situations where we're not exactly sure
how to contribute what we should be
prioritizing so let's talk about the top
three priorities that you should have
when you're in this new or novel
[Music]
situation I'm Alex line and I'm here to
provide professional development tips to
help you increase your impact and lead
your teams with more Excellence if you
have never subscribed to this channel
before I'd like to invite you to do so I
think all of these videos help people
that I call Rising leaders if you're a
team leader Frontline supervisor or
Frontline manager everything on here is
meant to help you sharpen your skills so
go ahead and subscribe thumbs up the
video if you like it start commenting in
the section below I'm really good about
responding to almost every single
comment people post so we can start a
dialogue okay now on to the lesson I
don't know about you but a lot of times
times I feel like my old moves that my
old team might not translate to a new
setting so now I'm with higher level
people or people I don't know that well
and I'm not really sure how to jump in
and contribute in a meaningful way so
let's talk about three ways that you can
instantly position yourself as a
credible contributor to that group
number one open a Communication channel
that means non-verbally and verbally
open a line of communication to to every
other single person in that room so
let's just picture a room with several
other people and you walk into this
situation you should instantly attempt
to make eye contact with every other
person in the room you also verbally
want to say something to each person if
you can if it's appropriate minimally
there people next to you but certainly
everybody if this is pre-meeting if
you're making small talks so you open
non-verbal and verbal Channel if there's
if it's appropriate and there's someone
close enough to you shake their hand
especially if it's before the meeting is
starting especially if you're just
introducing yourself most most places
are still okay with handshakes I know a
lot of places like don't touch it's not
okay to touch but a handshake is still
considered appropriate and professional
and then maintain during the course of
that meeting continue to make eye
contact continue to orient your body
toward people you don't want to fall
into the Trap of looking down at your
computer or your devices the entire time
in fact I have a whole separate video
about the downside of using devices in
meeting I encourage you to watch that
I'll put a link in the description below
this video to that one so that's the
first step is opening a channel and
maintaining that channel the entire
meeting the second step is to learn
every person's name when I know
someone's name I feel really equipped to
have a conversation with them because I
know who they are hopefully they knew
who I am and now at least you have a way
to refer to that person you know their
identity so what I like to do is I sit
down at these meetings especially in a
new situation I take out an
old-fashioned piece of paper and I write
down everyone's name a lot of time
people will introduce themselves for
example and as they go around I make
notes about who's who and that way
throughout the meeting I can look at my
notes and if I have a little down moment
where I'm not doing anything that's too
hard I look down at the list and I look
at their faces and I rehearse their
names in my head to really make sure I
ingrain those names and own those names
by the end of that meeting I really have
memorized everybody in the room it's
really not that hard if you put just a
little bit of effort into it so now you
know everybody's name the third step to
contributing is to make sure you add
some kind of value to that meeting so
you don't just want to listen although
listening is good you don't just want to
be non-verbally involved although
nonverbals are good you want to do
things like offer your opinion at least
once or twice offer some information ask
a question that leads the group in a
positive Direction build on something
that somebody else has said that's a
really easy way to get involved you want
to make sure you say something if you're
at that meeting you have to realize even
if you're brand new people expect you to
contribute and say something of value
from the very first meeting you can't
just sit around and ramp up over the
course of two three four meetings they
want you contributing right away in fact
I said something really useless in fact
there's a little confrontational at a
meeting once among some very high level
people and I felt kind of embarrassed
and I clammed up and afterwards I said
to my boss I'm really sorry that I said
that that was stupid I should have
thought about my words more carefully he
put his hand on my shoulder and he said
Alex at least you said something
otherwise we're all going to start
wondering what you were paying we were
paying you for I thought wow that's a
pretty graceful response but even at
that level people want you contributing
they want you from the very first
meeting to say something where you add
value so don't be shy about it break the
ice contribute verbally something so
those are the three ways that you can
prioritize your work in these meetings
and it is work you have to go in with a
little bit of a plan into these meetings
so that you show up as a professional as
someone who's credible as someone who
should be taken seriously by the other
people in the group so I I mentioned
earlier if you haven't yet subscribed I
encourage you to do so I encourage you
to look around the channel find some
other videos that might help you move
your career forward help you move your
team forward and I look forward to
starting a conversation in the comment
section below this and other videos so
thanks God bless and I hope you get to
use the tips we're talking about in your
very next team meeting